bring you some more on our breaking news
out of Russia and that explosion at a
cafe in the city of Saint Petersburg Dr
Jabari joins us from Moscow Dawson what
can you tell us
well what we know at this point is that
a 40 year old member of the Russian
military by the name of ladman tatarsky
has died this man is not just an
ordinary Russian soldier he is a
well-known blogger who was reporting on
the conflict and he has written many
books in Russia he's well known for his
um
feelings and opinions about the Russian
military he was also a special
correspondent for the State tv as well
he was delivering the speech at a cafe
in St Petersburg this afternoon in the
very populated area in the city known as
University embankment in St Petersburg
and that's when an explosion happened
and uh he has been killed as a result of
it now this Cafe was packed with people
who had gathered to hear him speak
and officials at the moment say at least
16 other people have been injured in
this attack which officials are now
calling a terrorist attack and this 40
year old Vaseline tatarsky was someone
who was very adamantly supporting
Russian military activities in the
donbass region and the special military
operation as the Russians are calling it
in Ukraine in February 2022 he was in
donbass and he himself enlisted in the
Eastern Battalion of the Russian
military
and uh he was reportedly managing drones
and uh calculation making calculations
for uavs in the Russian military
um and so this attack is certainly uh
going to erase some serious questions
about the safety of Russian soldiers
even off the battlefield and uh what the
Russian military will say we'll have to
wait and see in the coming hours but
certainly it's going to be seen as a
direct attack on Russian soil uh as it
happened in St Petersburg
all right thanks so much Dr Jabari there
let's continue this though with Pavel
falgenhauer he's a defense and Military
analyst joins us from Moscow good to
have you with us so first of all what do
we know about any sign any indication of
who might be responsible
well right now no one took
responsibility
but the attack was apparently
targeting a kind of program one a pro
war activists or Patriots or call
so-called Z people who because the the
English letter Z is the symbol the
Russian soldiers put on their tanks and
other vehicles and these it's a sign of
those who support the Russian operation
in Ukraine and it was a targeted attack
against those people and the speaker
there at this Gathering of these
activists was a well-known figure
an activist and a blogger and a
volunteer so this was a targeted kind of
attack on those who are who support the
operation in Ukraine we had an incident
I'm sure you recall Pavel in August of
last year where a TV personality a TV
commentator Daria dugina was killed by
an explosion she again a daughter of a
figure that's known to be very much Pro
Kremlin
Pro or even inspirational figure we are
told for President Putin is a pattern
here we don't want to speculate about
who's responsible is a pattern emerging
here of the sort of profile of people
who are being killed in these kinds of
mysterious explosions
uh yes such attacks had happened before
there were different attacks in the Don
bus itself against say those who
supported the operation especially those
inside the operational zones like those
who worked in Russian administrations
have taken over so there are many
attacks of that style in the donbas
there was attack on dugina close to
Moscow in the suburbs of Moscow
so there's mostly such attacks have been
happening in the donbas uh lesser extent
inside Russia this is maybe the second
such a serious attack against the
well-known figure it could become a
pattern uh if we're some kind if I don't
know I don't know who that may be
maybe some kind of Ukrainian groups I
don't know but this could become a
serious pattern if there's going to be
other attacks inside deep inside Russia
and Moscow in Saint Petersburg
um
whatever official investigation said in
relation to some of those previous
explosions which we've been talking
about
[Music]
the Ukrainian specials of services they
did not really deny it most likely
believing that this was legit
the Russian authorities link directly
also to Ukraine the ukrainians didn't
confirm
uh so basically I believe that this
there's going to be investigation we'll
have to find out what but that uh kind
of could speculate uh that the from the
finger from Moscow will be pointing at
Kiev
all right and as we look at the impact
of these sorts of attacks how is it
impacting public opinion public
sentiment in Russia particularly support
for the war
[Music]
it's a fact long lasting on the uh
support of the war
but the bringing I mean Russia's more or
less kind of normal there's uh all that
fighting in Ukraine there bombings
there's uh missile attacks all over the
country in Russia there is some activity
close very close to the Border
um but and inside Ukraine but basically
Russia is a peaceful country of course a
lot of people go to the war someone get
killed some get wounded quite a number
but the country is living kind of a
normal life the war is far somewhere far
away
oh relatively normal such a tank is that
bring the war close into the big Russian
cities into its capital and Saint
Petersburg the old capital
that's uh maybe of course may change
public opinion to some extent if this
becomes a very constant pattern of
attack all right and in this latest
instance of course we've had a blogger
that's been killed perhaps uh others we
we know that other people have been at
the very least wounded in this attack
give us an idea of how influential how
popular and prominent was the figure
that the Blogger who was killed
Loki was known especially in the uh
so-called Zed Circles of the of
supporters of the Russian operation and
this was a gathering of a club of people
of activists that support the operation
so this was I say this was a targeted
attack I wouldn't say that he has kind
of
very well known it didn't appear much on
Russian television not that he's a
national figure at all now Circle he
didn't have any kind of uh security
detail he's not an official
uh but well known at least
in in in the internet and in the circles
that support the operation
and I understand he had what over half a
million followers on telegram he's seen
as supportive of the war but also at
times he's been critical he's had
critical commentary on on aspects of the
war is that right
the Russian authorities especially the
military command saying that modern
mistakes had been done which is obvious
and the operation is not going as
planned at all and their heavy losses so
yes sir that's a criticism from those
parts is uh well rather widespread but I
don't think that the far this kind of
such an attack who had anything to do
with the Russian authorities because you
see most of these figures criticize if
not the operation but now it's being
performed
how significant do you think it is that
this attack now took place in Saint
Petersburg a very historical city in
Russia of course
well yes it's the old capital and uh
there was apparently some kind of uh
with such a such targeted attacks there
would be a group maybe not the very big
one but still uh
organizing it and it took time to
because you have to
make a
explosive device it's not kind of that
he could buy it in the store in Russia
and then you have to find and directly
Target the person you want to find you
that requires until that requires up uh
the involvement of operators to
understand how to use explosives so this
was an operation that took time to plan
and perform so this was a plant it's not
an improvisation it was of course
planned and planned thoroughly
all right thank you so much Pavel
loganhauer there
and also Jabari joins us from Moscow
once again so Dawson what are officials
saying any details yet on uh who they
think may be responsible for this
no Sammy I think it's still too early
for that at the moment what we're still
trying to figure out is how this would
have happened
um and the status of those people
injured as well this was an event that
was well publicized where it is 40 year
old a well-known military blogger
um
tarsky was speaking and this is a
reoccurring event apparently organized
by a group
um known as The cyberfund Zed movement
um and they hold up weekly events and he
was the guest keynote speaker at this
Cafe in the heart of Saint Petersburg on
what is known as the university
embankment in uh Saint Petersburg he was
seeking at the event started at about 5
PM local time uh their time in St
Petersburg and the attack took place
shortly after he took the stage area
that was together in this Cafe at least
16 people have been injured so far but
it really I think is
um very very significant uh given where
things stand at the moment in the
country uh with this so-called special
military operation at the person who
died in this attack the
um famous blogger the pro Kremlin
blogger vladlin tatarsky is someone who
enlisted in the Russian military in
February of 2022 in the Eastern unit of
the Russian military and he was in
donbass as well
and he's very much made his views clear
on this military operation being very
supportive and when the Russian
President Vladimir Putin uh signed a
decree including those four regions of
Ukraine into uh Russia in September uh
he was very much supportive and said
that this is how it should be and
everything will come back to Russia and
Russia will be as it was before so you
get a sense of uh what he believed in
and what his writings are about he's
written a number of books uh about war
and Russia's military past as well so I
think this attack points to the
divisions within the country that are
not certainly vocalized as much but as
the guest pointed out earlier this was
very much a well thought out planned out
calculated attack that was carried out
and uh most likely the
um intended target would be the person
that they killed
all right thanks so much dorsa Jabari
there updating us on developments coming
out of Russia and talking about those
developments let's look at some pictures
which have come in there you go you can
see that we're told is the moment of the
blast
as you can see it took out a lot of the
the front glass windows a cafe in Saint
Petersburg
was the site of that attack we're told
and the target a pop a popular blogger
who had himself participate as well
commented on the war in Ukraine